hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 160 q a
segment about to go
oh the more cats now with more cats well
fewer cats oh less cats than just a
moment ago
which one is it
which calf fewer cats or less cats I
think it's fewer uh yeah I think less
refers to collective nouns
yeah yeah less catch by weight
it's not usually we measure cats no no
all right uh q a here we are
we seem this uh the Discord question for
the week uh is actually something that
we largely covered in the first
um
first hour but I will ask the question
see if uh either of us have anything to
add we seem to have entered a coveted
retconning phase instead of a reckoning
phase they are retroactively changing
the facts and Narrative of the past
right for the wrong reasons to imply
that there was never any legitimate
basis for skepticism is there a concise
contemporaneous reference to demonstrate
clearly what was done at the time to
debunk these arguments by folks like
Harris and Adams
foreign
yes
I don't I don't know of one yeah I don't
either uh I will say that I think the
game is not to convince anybody who was
following along the game uh
dissuade all of those who
uh got suckered from finding a better
source of information so it's a matter
of
um people who really should be retracing
their steps preserving what uh seems to
some like credibility and preventing
audiences from seeking higher quality
sources
so I don't know about whether a
reference
would be useful but no I'm not aware of
one oh I think it would be very useful
not to everyone but being able to
respond with you know just just as I
have been responding to Clemson or
contrarian with like actually here not a
contrarian here's it and you know I
wrote a short piece on like why science
is not contrarianism and I don't know
that it manifests you know in the brains
of the the people who are the loudest
with the biggest audiences but some
people will see it you know I see the
upticks in readers and in in such uh
whenever whenever that is whenever I do
that so uh I I would like to know and I
would invite people who are watching if
you can think of a concise
contemporaneous which gosh could mean
anything from like
end of 2020 through
I don't know most of 2021 really half of
um
any any kind of you know coveted careful
analysis uh that really lays out a
number of these pieces you know a lot of
a lot of people in including me and
including us have written careful pieces
but they tend to be either you know both
very narrow and also very long because
it's very hard to do concise
um at all in this landscape and it's
also very hard to cover all of the bases
yeah I mean I guess I'm not really sure
contemporaneous with what
the since the argument is
um
there was no reason for skepticism at
the time yeah they ended up right by
accident
um no no one reasonable was questioning
this then even though everyone reason
was questioning it now right like that's
the insane argument that some people are
making and contemporaneous is okay when
we were skeptical what was the basis of
the skepticism yeah
um uh you know in some sense
unfortunately it's the podcast and
somebody would have to say the opposite
of concise yeah it's not concise but
it's all contained there and I don't
know what else there would be for the
reasons that you you point out so
anyway but it doesn't have to be us like
so you know some a number of people are
have been thinking and writing and you
know and and talking but I don't I don't
have I don't know that this thing exists
unfortunately yep
okay
now we're going to the questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com totally different
topics
can you guys elaborate a bit more on the
biological and evolutionary element on
the genetics of body types it seems to
me that people might be a bit like dogs
we have our Saint Bernards and our
Greyhounds neither can escape their
default genetic body types it also seems
that it would be difficult to eat well
exercise and take care of the body and
still be obese so while it is absurd to
suggest weight is entirely genetic some
people certainly default to vastly
different ranges why is this
and I think the piece that is missing
from this
question I don't see anywhere here is
development and that's going to be such
a such a huge piece of the puzzle so you
know as we as we have said many times as
we have written into our book
you know a Maasai and an Inuit person
are
um their body types exist existed came
to be in such different environments
that uh in the far north being closer to
spherically shaped uh made more sense
because uh a lower surface area volume
ratio retained heat and in the African
Savannah you want higher surface area to
volume ratio in order to radiate heat
and so you get tall and thin in the open
Savannah at the equator and shorter and
rounder the farther towards the poles
you get that is obviously you know a
generality but for those two two named
populations of people who the entire
world recognizes as named populations of
people
um that that applies and so those are
easy relative extremes right and most of
us you know most Americans are mutts we
come from a lot of different places
um
and so there's going to be a lot of
different stuff contributing to what our
body size and shape is
um what we get exposed to and now that
we're exposed to so many things that
come into us as if they were food but
aren't food as kids can radically change
metabolism and so it is no longer true
it may well have been true 100 years ago
500 years ago 10 000 years ago that as
you write if you eat well exercise and
take care of your body you won't be
obese
I don't know that that's true anymore I
think um people people with development
developmental environments in which they
are given extraordinarily bad
information in the form of pseudo-food
may be stuck with May well be stuck with
weight loss issues no matter how many
things they change as adults and that is
something that we've done to ourselves
not the individual the individuals
um are not to be held accountable here
for what is done to them as children but
we as a species have done to ourselves
yeah we've uh screwed up the
precautionary principle across all these
things yeah I would say that it's also
not just the content the molecular
content of what we take in but the
um boom and bust cycles that simulate
famine also yeah well I mean we know
that these things trigger epigenetic
changes that cause the body to store
different amounts of stuff because if
you think about it
um
every extra ounce you store is costly
every step you take
and so there's a bias towards not
carrying extra and that is balanced
against the need to store enough
calories to get through lean times and
so to the extent that we are sending
messages that cause the body to
misunderstand what time of year it is
misunderstand how regular the food
supply is or any of these things you may
trigger these patterns
even before you get to things like
hormones
that we feed to farm animals in order to
trigger them to put on weight faster
that then we hide behind the belief that
because it's not detectable in the milk
that the signal isn't there when in fact
a hormone is designed to be a signal at
extremely low concentrations of the fact
that your chemical assay doesn't find it
doesn't say that your hormone receptors
don't find it
yep
um
anything else to add here I'm gonna I
think there's a
a lot some people certainly default to
vastly different ranges yes this is true
well I think you know you've got several
different parameters you've got
body type to begin with based on things
like what population you've got you
can't be your lineage came from yep
you've got things like developmental
uh exposure to things that simulate
famine you've got developmental exposure
to things like hormones that affect
the regulation of weight
and then you have
uh toxins which may disrupt the normal
function and all of those things and
toxins include uh not just like
glyphosate but also sugar and seed oil
those are estrogens from Plastics all
sorts of things
basic point is you've got a system that
is built for a world of a much more
limited it's not that the number of
molecules is all that limited but the
number of types of molecules you are
likely to encounter and in what sorts of
quantities was much more limited and all
of those things result in the setting of
some set point and that set point is
something that people struggle against
in adulthood because the body has picked
an arbitrary number that makes sense for
some environment that doesn't really
exist and
um
uh much better to set these things in
youth now the question is
in the scenario they lay out what would
happen for a child who had good exercise
habits
and ate a proper number of calories if
the quality of the food wasn't all that
high in other words it had the
contaminants and hormones and things and
it'd be an interesting thing to know
yeah that's not in the question but
that's you know that's that's part of
how we're answering it yep
dogs and eating healthfully my dog is
allergic to chicken and beef since puppy
vaccinations she's five and eating
prescription diet of hydrolyzed protein
I would love to get her off of it she
can eat fish and pork I'd love to feed
her tuna I thought it was high in
mercury though can you share what you
feed your dogs
well we only feed one of our dogs
um because we don't love the other one
actually it's because we only have one
dog
yes that's that's the reason right there
yeah she's snoring in the background she
can attest that we love her very much
um
yeah uh some tuna is high in mercury
actually uh consumer lab I want to say
uh which is better than consumer reports
and does or it's different it does it
basically does Consumer Report style
things but a bit more carefully uh for
things uh like supplements and
um
and also food just did an analysis of
mercury levels in different uh different
brands of canned tuna and they found
actually wildly different wildly
different levels and some of them
um you know as far as what we are
currently saying seemed you know within
safe levels for humans dogs are smaller
than humans so you know what's safe for
humans should definitely be safe for
dogs but if it's the entire thing that
you're feeding them as actually we feed
our cats almost entirely tuna if you're
if they're getting it every day that is
potentially an issue yeah we have been
driven to do that by food sensitivities
so you know it's not like it's a good
solution to the problem but you know if
you're feeding your animal stuff that
the animal is allergic to that's a
critical problem and as you've probably
experienced if you're down to hydrolyzed
protein you're probably you've probably
gone through some
um alternative Foods
and basically the hydrolyzed stuff has
been reduced in size so it's not
triggering but it's not a good solution
either now I don't one of our sponsors
is Sundays they do
um
they make dog food uh that is fantastic
I do not remember I know they have at
least two two and I don't remember if
one of them is chicken one of those beef
but if they if they have a non-chicken
non-beef uh brand uh Maddie loves it and
it's really good for her
um
yeah you know I mean raw raw meat you
know fish and pork you're talking about
um having to spend a lot of money and a
lot of time
um but that's you know that's that's
what they should be eating yeah and you
might be able to make a deal on scrap
raw food it's like you're not feeding
them human grade stuff not by virtue the
fact that it isn't good quality but by
virtue of the fact that it's fattier
little bits and pieces and yeah yeah
totally
oh another animal question our cat has
asthma
I have read that CBD fish oil and honey
can reduce inflammation in cats and help
manage their asthma do you have any
thoughts or experience giving
supplements to cats thank you
[Music]
um I mean we pilled cats
every cat is different
um so that's a different question I
guess I'll I'll address that one first
which is that you like
having loved cats since I was very small
and Having learned to dissect uh cat
cadavers in graduate school and then
taught comparative anatomy lab many many
times as a professor
I have a really good sense of what
musculature on a cat skull is like and I
can say that if you know your cat well
and if you are very very careful at
first you can you can kind of get them
to pop their jaw open by going after the
the jaw hinge and um and then just clamp
it shut once you get something inside
and stroke their neck and they will
generally swallow it it's not perfect
if the cat escapes before they've
swallowed it and they will will pull
like a was it the Jack Nicholson
character and One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest as you know presumably mental
patients everywhere who are on to the
game will you know hide the pill under
their tongue or something and then
wander off and unlike the Jack Nicholson
character in one flew of the Cougars
Nest the cats will distribute dispose of
the pill like under the couch or
something and you'll never know
which is a problem so a pilling of cats
is both about your particular
relationship with your particular cat
who the particular cat is but then there
are some universals of anatomy and
physiology that you can leverage to your
uh to your benefit that said we haven't
had to pill any cats for a very long
time we've not been giving our cats any
anything nor do nor are they in any any
drugs that aren't recreational that we
know of yeah exactly occasionally from
catnip
you don't have to force that down their
throats no anything I've never heard of
CBD fish oil or honey for reducing
inflammation cats I do feel feel like um
again depending on your situation
keeping honey to cats could result in
having to reupholster a lot of things
yeah
um yeah I've never heard of asthma in
cats that doesn't surprise me terribly
that it exists but it does surprise me
that I haven't encountered it yeah
but uh I do Wonder in in a case like
this if there's not something triggering
the cat and you might not be better off
figuring out what that thing is you know
so yeah yeah yeah
um I had what was called cough variant
asthma that went away completely at the
point that I got past uh when I realized
I had a wheat allergy and got rid of it
so
question about whether or not you're
trigging triggering an inflammatory
state with something and then you're
going to treat it with something else
where you'd be better off getting rid of
the inflammatory State yeah and that
that's why I read this question after
the last one
um that the the previous person it was
it was dogs but
has identified what they what they think
and which seems totally plausible we
know this to happen
um our allergies to a few common uh
proteins and dog food
um due to you know puppy vaccinations
and that leaves the animal on a much
limited diet presumably because there
are lots of symptoms manifesting when
they're not on that limited diet but
asthma being one of these things that
until that until your experience I had
never heard of that yeah as a as an
effect of weed intolerance or gluten
intolerance or or you know really any of
these sorts of
um
dietary intolerances so uh you became so
overall healthier in every regard yeah
when you took uh when you took wheat out
of your diet that uh it struck me that
uh anytime someone has a general
condition where especially if a doctor
has been like oh it's idiopathic right
that's the word right like which means
we don't know
um you know can consider that it's a
dietary allergen yeah yeah I would also
consider uh
vitamin D was on your list of things no
no I would consider vitamin D and I
would consider vitamin D over a long
enough period of time that it is likely
to have an effect
um
yeah I don't know I don't know what
dosage I don't know how how you get
vitamin D into a cat or what dosage
you're not going to give them 5000 I use
vitamin D no but it seems to me that the
easy thing to do is to cut open one of
those capsules and put it on food and
their lives will smear it on their nose
and they'll take it off right
um but anyway
yeah I mean that is that is one thing
you can do I wouldn't do it with any of
these CBD fish oil and honey you don't
want to smear those things on the cat
and expect them to lick them off no fish
oil they might they would drink honey
like if you make like a warm not super
hot like a tea
you know cats don't usually drink tea
Zach yeah
just saying a cat Sweet Water is very
attractive to any anything and I think
if they're not bees I think they would
love a honey not like way over strong
you don't want to be too hot either
a dog yes but a cat I don't know the
dog's not oh you could give her a jar of
honey initial yeah
okay a couple of uh sports questions
apropos our conversation earlier oh that
does raise a point oh wait actually oh
wait there's another there's a follow-up
to the one we just read and if you know
of anything that help a cat with asthma
please do tell thanks to you both again
so we we maybe vitamin D but the other
yeah but like think about dietary
triggers think about dietary triggers
also there's a question about whether or
not you could put some
a meat-based soup
that then you had laced with totally CBD
and oh yeah honey and stuff like that
that might work yeah bone broth yeah
okay I play eight and nine ball
competitively the understanding within
the sport which I find to be an anomaly
myself is that the best women cannot
realistically compete at the highest
level with the best men
seeming Chen I don't recognize the name
so I'm probably butchering her name
might be the only current exception to
this could this relate to boys engaging
in hand-eye activities at a much younger
age and more frequently in the aggregate
at a cultural level have man had a
stronger evolutionary need to develop
certain hand-eye and muscle memory
skills what do you think
yeah
it's it's in this case it's obviously
not about root strength you don't you
know anyone presumably
um Can wield a
wield a queue
um but uh the hand-eye coordination
question I think
um I'm just I'm trying to think of the
places that we know that are established
that even the naysayers will agree like
okay right manipulating objects in
three-dimensional space in your mind is
something that men are more likely to be
able to do than women and
um textual uh you know text recognition
uh is something that women are are have
greater facility with than men those are
those are two of the ones that um that
show up but like you know hand-eye
coordination I kind of don't see why not
right like given
um given a history of
um
given a history of of men more being
more likely to use tools to capture
things
uh but I haven't seen the analysis
yeah I'm just not even sure that this is
a necessary
hypothesis to explain it because the
number of if you just simply take the
following as an assumption
more men will explore their skill
at pool
then the point is you're dealing with a
larger population the Tails of that
distribution include more people you're
going to reach farther into the extremes
and so if you just simply so the best
professional billiards players are not
necessarily the best of what the
population had to offer because you were
pulling from a smaller small population
right you're pulling yeah and so anyway
if it is true that more men pursue pool
enough to get rewarded and reach the
highest levels than women then you would
expect the women to be less
extraordinary because you're censusing a
much smaller population even if they
were even if you census all men and all
women and they were dead even right so
um that's an annoying explanation
because it doesn't really and it would
actually predict it's
I don't think it's annoying it's a
little hard to explain but why is it
annoying well it's annoying because you
see a pattern which is oh yeah the women
of the sport aren't able to compete with
the top men and it's like oh actually
that has nothing to do with male and
female it has to do with well no but it
does have to do with male and female it
just it starts earlier yeah it has to do
with
um
Tendencies
to pursue rather than capacity to to
accomplish well on this yeah this is the
literature that I delved into uh during
and after the whole Google memo debacle
in which uh James demore uh made the out
just outlandish claim um that uh men and
women
um are are different in some ways and
have different interests I know I know
can you believe it the audacity of that
guy
um and I
my first thought was like yeah obviously
and then you go into the literature the
the good part of the literature on on
these questions of course there's a lot
of bad literature there's a lot of bad
science everywhere
um but the good science on these
questions
um very often very often end up being
ones of like actually different
interests we you know we find no
evidence for different capacity between
this axis but we do have different
interests and then once you have
different interests then you start
canalizing and the canalization results
in exactly as you say
um sort of smaller populations among the
less interested sex that the best of the
best are being drawn from and so it's
not the best of it it's the best of a
smaller best as opposed to the best of
the larger best and you've drawn some
cute little uh is that a is that an
anaconda that's eaten a capybara or no
no no no no no these are two no no no
hold it back
oh it's out of focus right that's
perfect yeah okay but you forgot the
head
um um so these are two normal
distributions
you could get fancy they could be power
laws but anyway the point is
um they have the same mean but so these
are but so it's an intentional that the
x-axis is different on the two of them
or that's just the way you drew it
that's just because they suck at drawing
um well and like non-existent but
implied differently okay right anyway
the point is the
um the x-axis here is awesomeness at
pool right these people are not awesome
at pool so not awesome um yeah in fact
they're so bad at pool that they could
drown at it even though it's not an
aquatic sport
what
it is spelled the same yeah yeah
um over here you have people who are
extremely awesome these are men a larger
population so the same shape curve a
larger number of people gives you you
explore further into the tale of the
distribution of pool awesomeness than
you do in a small population where you
do have some awesome players but they
are much less
far down this uh this leg of the
distribution so anyway the idea that
there is a player who may be an
exception to this rule is actually a
prediction of that model well I feel
like are you miked yeah okay I'm like I
feel like that lower normal distribution
the one that you imply is women's pool
players yeah or when pool players should
be shifted over to the right because
people because women who explore their
talented pool should be more likely to
do so if they're natively better or
better in some realm I agree so it made
I bet it will be not actually I bet the
men's one will be closer to actually
evenly on either side of that
Center Line and the women's one will be
stretched in some different ways it
depends what that's a graph of if I
understand your critique then you're
probably right women who take up pool
and men who take up pool
but if the point is anybody who's ever
picked up a pool cue or anybody who's
ever you know played five games or more
right then it will look more more like
this
um you know no one can see that no but I
feel like yeah
I also think that a majority I think
that the same number of women and men
roughly will have played a game of pool
I don't think that's going to differ
tremendously everyone will ever there
are plenty of people maybe that is
changing no I think there are lots of
people who don't have access to pool
tables or whatever but nobody didn't
like him in bars like you know there
used to be often a pool table and a lot
of sort of diving bars and lots of
diving bars but at least at least used
to be I think I'm not never spent time
in these sorts of scenarios grew up with
a pool table myself so I didn't have to
go to Dive Bar
um but my sense at least from sort of
the representation in popular culture is
that sometimes women would play but
mostly it was the dudes playing and the
women sort of standing around admiring
their skill no but that's what I mean I
think since they're in the same
environment
the same number of women roughly will
have played at least a game even if the
men end up playing hundreds of games for
every woman that plays a game in a dive
bar
I think if you're in those scenarios
with the pool table as a main feature
well I don't know that's my sense I
guess I'm not sure what the what the
prediction is what the point is well
then that graph should actually be of
um
of men and women that pursue pool
professionally and that the women should
be shifted over farther farther to the
right because there are more
in any case I think we've got what we
need okay you got a tail of a
distribution or people who try the thing
the farther down the tail you're going
to explore and
uh that could well explain it even if
there is no inherent advantage to being
male and playing pool yep and that's not
to say that there couldn't be yeah a
male Advantage but
um I like this I find this
non-irritating as an explanation because
uh the observation that apparently pool
players uh billiards players are making
can be true and that can be not about
intrinsic differences in capacity yes it
can be and actually you would expect
over time
if you take so you've got the population
of women who play pool at any one moment
and then you've got the population with
any within any generation and then
you've got the population of have ever
played pool and the point is you should
explore further down that tail of the
distribution the longer
right you the more people in your sex
who play the more of that tale of the
distribution will be explored and so you
would expect women over time to produce
uh well and yeah and so yes and exactly
why we expect to see over time also you
know put aside pool let's talk about
representation in science and not and we
can do we don't even we don't have to
limit it to sex we can do race right
like if if Western science has been the
purview of rich white guys for a very
long time
um then it is it is only going to be
more recently that people who didn't
look like that have been able to go like
oh yeah actually
um I could go into that and for you know
until yesterday practically it was much
harder to you know grow up as someone
who didn't have a long line of people
who looked like them and go like yeah
that's what I want to do so you know
this is this is the place where
representation actually can make a
difference like oh you need someone you
don't need someone but it can be useful
to have someone in history who looks
something like you who you recognize
yourself in to sort of open the door to
aspiring to it yep
another Sports question
I see a major difference between
objective Sports races soccer hockey
subjective Sports diving gymnastics
figure skating and hybrid Sports boxing
is subjective for KO for knockout but
subjective for a decision
to me it seems that males grab a grab a
bait that's not
to me it seems that males gravitate to
objective and females to subjective
sports do you agree and what is the
biological reason if so
um
if I feel like that's probably true but
then I'm thinking about
you know the Olympics yeah has you know
each of these
each of these have male and female uh
well except except as we talked about
like I don't know is there female hockey
yeah because there's people hockey
there's not really female football so
much maybe that's not very
Female Hockey yeah I mean like girls
play hockey and women play hockey but
we're talking about like pickup games
and such
um
I feel like that's probably true even
though my thinking about like who's
playing sports in the world seems to
suggest it's not necessarily but I feel
like it's probably true precisely
because of the thing that we've been
talking about with regard to the
different ways that men and women tend
to compete
and so it's not that women aren't
interested in competition and in
um
but but it's it's more often about
it's more often about social competition
right then then competition over a
physical uh a a physical barrier
well I'm not sure that we're not talking
about the same thing in other words this
may be explanatory
about uh different styles of competition
that are sexually different but
if it is true
that objective Sports tend to be things
in which
simple measures like power
matter
than you would expect there to be a
historical bias because
um it doesn't make sense if you're a
woman and you're not going to be as
powerful as the most powerful man you're
not going to be winning in competitions
where power is the thing
well unless there's sex segregation in
sports right which is a relatively
recent thing I believe
so the point is you would imagine that
there would be some bias uh in you know
you're more rewarded in a sport where
you can succeed and so you might imagine
that there's been just a bias in the
direction of those more uh artistic
Precision oriented
um sports that has very little to do
with anything fundamental it has to do
with you know I can be best in the world
at this thing in part because part of
the assessment of best in the world is
something where I'm not handicapped on
account of being a woman yep
yep
um interesting this this idea of hybrid
sports and what are there other sports
that are hybrid
uh and you know maybe to some degree
there's always a little bit because even
um you know the objective Sports have
referees exactly uh but uh barring
barring calls that are required by
referees to um
to decide to make decisions about Fells
and such some of them like figure
skating
figure skating there's some sort of set
of
points yeah they're it's it's hybrid
hybrid ish yeah
it's hybrid it's hybrid ish although
um
yeah and I guess what do you call the
and I don't know any of the names of any
of the jumps or anything but you know
there's a there's a list made in advance
by some human
something yeah that says a successful
Landing of this is worth this and you
know here are the 10 things that this
person might attempt and here's what
each of them are worth if they're
successful and so if you s and you know
still there's going to be sort of points
for like Artistry and and how much do
you deduct if it wasn't a perfect
Landing but it was kind of good you know
there's a ton of subjectivity but
there's also
at least a a numerical thing that look
it's like
quasi-quantitative that exists in
advance of the person taken to the ice
yeah yeah that's the same same thing I
was getting at this it's
did you and didn't you and how many
points is it worth is an objective
measure if it's done right yeah and then
there's subjectivity on top of that but
yeah and again there's also subjectivity
from refs in yeah soccer and I think um
diving
diving in gymnastics are going to be
very very similar with regard to that
you know this and I
can't remember the last time I watched
diving but you know the Olympics
whenever whenever that was
um
like they walk up and you're told okay
this person is attempting an X dive and
a perfect X dive is worth this number of
points and then you'll hear uh like oh
uh that wasn't perfectly executed
therefore right like oh I couldn't tell
yeah
uh
Jordan Peterson's trickle-down logic
sounds like uh in richer poorest then
they'll care more about the environment
and then the Earth will improve sounds
Noble but does it hold water
depends how it's done
yeah
um yep the problem is if all you do you
know if you could instantly snap your
fingers
and uh make the poor
wealthy in the sense then it would
greatly increase
consumption of things that are not
sustainably produced if this happens
over time in some sort of plausible way
maybe and I would point out that there
are game changers that we have to think
about
in what way do they arrive like fusion
power
they could change everything right
Jordan Peterson's view of how to have a
population of the world that is
all wealthy enough to give a damn about
the future
um could be is plausible if given fusion
power this is an argument we make in our
book in the last chapter
um but if you just dumped fusion power
on the system at the moment it would
probably make things worse and not
better so anyway the devil's in the
details is I think the answer yep
if you had a 15 year old daughter who
claimed to be non-binary and wanted to
go by them they pronouns how would you
handle it
um it's in some ways trickier I was I
was thinking I think I said on air about
this uh
dad who responded to his daughter
claiming to be trans
um by saying hey honey so am I and
showing up at school
bedecked in a gown and uh acting
ridiculous and the daughter got cured of
that delusion right quick because her
father embarrassed her so badly which I
think was just
brilliant
um exceedingly good dad mom work in this
case
yes such good dad mom dad work
um
but the whole Envy thing the whole
non-binary thing is
um
so trans is almost always in the modern
day and age uh especially in teenage
girls
um delusional it's it's it's social
Contagion
but it's con it's it's about move
becoming one thing from another thing
both of which are real mammals just
can't do that
non-binary and they them pronouns this
is entirely social construct Universe
there's like there's no there there
there's no no thing that you can be like
oh but like it's just it's just a
fantasy
um in every regard like I'm I'm neither
this nor that
but you know you are actually so I don't
I don't have a good like what I don't
know I mean the problem is you you know
if
you you need the actual child in order
to yeah the question yeah there's not
going to be a script you can't script it
right you can't script it I would say I
would not indulge the pronoun thing at
all even if your kid is trans
well in this case it's not trans
yeah non-binary
um that just means your kid's not good
at computer science but
um
not funny because computer science is
binary I see
it was pretty good once you get by the
horrifying interpretation of the joke
and you get to the mathematical it's
pretty funny but um
uh
I saw you briefly considered divorce and
then I saw you reject it for which I'm
grateful
um but uh
I I wouldn't engage the pronoun thing at
all right the fact is this is an
authoritarian move no matter what else
might be true of your kid the idea that
you are going to force a change in
language that is not a
um
that is a destruction of an actual
information carrying aspect of speech
doesn't make sense it's not it's not a
kid's right to do that
I guess
um
this is probably not exactly the right
move but I have directed a few people uh
who have people in their families
who were playing around in the space
um the piece that I wrote called what do
girls do
um and you know the answer is girls
become women that's what girls do and
some girls
um you know play in the mud and and
drive trucks and do math and some girls
have tea parties for their bears and um
both in both cases they're girls and
they become women because that's what
girls do so I do think a lot of the
social contagiony
um fashion stuff around trans and now
non-binary is actually thinly veiled uh
misogynistic regressive gender
stereotypes from earlier
so you know what does it what does it
mean to you to be non-binary uh does it
mean that you don't
um feel
like you want to become a woman like
this is an awkward moment
like some of the trappings of of
Womanhood are
not what you're interested in doing uh
okay that's cool you can do whatever you
want
to be like men can do whatever they want
in life all the options are open and
same is true for women
if what you're telling me is that you
don't like the changes your body is
going through
well that's puberty like that's
adolescence and uh some people have an
easier time with it than others uh but a
lot of people uh I I think especially
girls although maybe that's just because
that's what people talk about
um but you know a lot of teenagers
really struggle with the changes that
their bodies go through as they
effectively metamorphose right like it
would be easier if we had chrysalises
but that's not human right like we need
to continue to experience the World As
We Go From child to adult and that
teenager stage can be very very
confusing and especially in a world
uh that is celebrating
um is celebrating non-binariness and
transness and
um sending incredibly incoherent and
confusing messages about what it is to
be a man or a woman uh then you know it
doesn't actually surprise me this sort
of the newest the newest fashionable
thing that's that's ridiculous and so is
that and I don't want to do any of this
and I'm kind of not feeling like I want
to be in the sexual landscape at all so
this is what I'm going to do like well
but that's not actually a category like
I know your friends say it's a category
but it's not like you are becoming a
woman and it's going to happen and uh
you can make of that any number of
things
and it doesn't it's going to be more
productive and amazing for you if you
don't obscure that behind some category
that uh that didn't even exist 10 years
ago
um I would recommend
that you as a parent listen to Jordan
Peterson's most recent uh Joe Rogan
appearance he goes through a dissection
of normal psychological changes that
girls face
uh and why that is fueling this
particular
bad
and I don't know whether or not
I don't know whether a kid could hear it
but I do think as a parent that having
heard it
will leave you somewhat better armed to
know what it is that you're confronting
in fact he talks about well but he only
talks about trance though I mean I agree
it's an excellent it's an excellent bit
of analysis that he does but this Envy
thing is different
I don't I'm not as compelled at that
because I think there's
true trans as we've talked about many
times then there's trans activism which
does seem to me like it is uh
escaping the same thing and so I'm just
not sure why the analysis of non-binary
and trans would be different it seems to
me it's exactly the same uh
psychological pathway that would lead
you there unless there was something
very specific going on
I'm not convinced but um
still I think you know he's he's a wise
man and those are wise words that he's
got in that uh most recent Rogan
appearance
speaking of
I have followed Dark Horse since Brett
one on Rogan I'm so very grateful to you
both are you familiar with Convention of
States if not please check it out just
maybe our way out of this mess do you
know this convention of states
that's not the I don't recognize it
it's not the Peterson thing that he
announced
he didn't give it a name
yeah I'm not sure I'll look into it
thank you
a hemorrhaged four liters of blood since
having my daughter in November I'm
having surgery soon in my Hemorrhage
again how can I mitigate the effects of
vaccinated blood transfusions
I mean there there are in in many in
many uh Healthcare environments the
ability to um
to request or to you know to get donor
blood to only receive blood that you
have had donated for for you
um that is challenging it's not an easy
it's not easy but if
um
if you have
if you have friends or family close who
are in a position to do so that strikes
me as a root in that is potentially very
useful you might also be able to donate
to yourself
probably not if not if she's temperature
that much
yeah but it's probably true yeah
um about cell regeneration being finite
do you have thoughts on facial chemical
appeals and things that expedite cell
turnover is there such a thing as too
much
yeah I think I think these are
disastrous and even even the uh more
ancient things like just exfoliation
right that um yeah there's definitely I
I think you know it feels good it feels
good to be in the sand right like just
just at the really basic like oh I'm not
applying something special to my face
here but
um you know it can feel good to Slough
off
um sort of layers of skin but is it uh
you know are all of your cells uh finite
in terms of their life you hope so
because otherwise you've got a different
problem right uh so yeah uh the more
often the more often you scrub the skin
off of your face the sooner it will uh
it will age and uh the the more likely
you discover some
um some truths about some of those
salons you didn't want to know
yeah I mean there are going to be two
things to it though so there's this
result
which I've described elsewhere where
dermatologists got surprised by people
who worked in the sun like Cowboys
um and had very wrinkled damaged skin
but no skin cancer
yeah so the basic
uh pattern is
things that accelerate the loss of skin
accelerate the Aging of the skin but
they also deplete the reproductive
capacity of cells that turns into cancer
when it runs away and I think this can
go too far
but I would not be surprised if
exfoliation accelerated the rate of
Aging of somebody's skin
um but had a a positive effect on uh
tumors if it was at least intermediate
yep
um the order of the frames on the wall
Disturbed me I would have put the
armadillo third up and the fishy fish in
the center or is that my mammal-centric
bias speaking
sure phylogenetic bias speaking but um
what's that we're not even subject
anymore
yeah they're really not what happened to
the table uh
okay yes nothing is nothing about this
is centered anymore
um
yeah no actually
you know there's the skull energy is not
a thing right there is no sort of
seeking to obtain a higher order in in
nature and
I would say it's not a phylogenic bias
because you could draw the correct
phylogenic tree of these three organisms
either in this configuration or with
efficiently armadillo reversed because
in that direction you know you've just
you're going to have you know the fish
in the armadillo are cyst I can't even
over the fish in the armadillo or sister
to one another and that Glade which is
the vertebrates or sister to the
non-vertebrate Heather he's trying to
tell you is that you can flip any node
on a phylogenetic tree and it remains
valid
yeah and uh you've got a node like
you're gonna you're gonna introduce node
and think that's clarifying hell yeah
that's pretty clear
a a place where two uh the two sister
taxa can be an in either in either
orientation relative to one another
um and you could also move the
I always want to say Nautilus and then
I'm wrong yeah
um so the m and I could be on the other
side of them both
all right uh why do some lizards appear
to be doing push-up push-ups is this
territorial Behavior mating behavior or
are they scoping out the terrain I love
the idea that they're scoping out the
train like I'm just gonna sit in here oh
wait I gotta see where that rise like a
spy hop yeah now I've never seen that
described I've watched a lot of lizards
do a lot of push-ups because it's kind
of kind of what I do and uh I've also
read a lot of literature on lizards
doing push-ups
um also kind of what I do and I've never
seen it described as actually like I'm
going to look over a thing now
um it's
maybe sometimes in some species uh
impressive to the the girl lizards but
mostly it's showing off to the to the
males it's territorial so it's push-ups
um
it's push-ups to demonstrate to other
males doing other push-ups in other
parts of the range uh that this is my
territory and I do the baddest push-ups
of them all so yes we effectively know
that it's not uh checking out the
territory because it would be males and
females
you mean you mean looking right trying
to scope it out to see what's there yeah
yeah and it's only it's only males
all right so that could be mating too
and I think again there's some evidence
for some you know sometimes the female
lizards will sort of their head and
like oh it's nice push-ups yeah but it's
definitely about male on male
uh impressive signal yes and uh and
animals they will actually do lap yeah
there's lots of amazing things lizards
do yeah all right so push-ups is is one
of the nearer to universals it's not
Universal but
um you know lots of lizards have all
sorts of fancy ornamentation but a lot
of them do this push-up thing I'm
realizing now that my story is on do
left and not push-ups
you know I I know the story you're going
to tell I think you should still tell it
um but I feel like I always imagined
that story when you were telling it he's
also doing this no
there may have been there may have been
but I don't recall it that way anyway I
was in Jamaica I was working with Bob
trivers uh on animals and I was doing
photography work where I was these
little iguanas photographing the Dew
laps and then we were trying to
correlate it with uh levels of infection
we're testing a hypothesis called the
Traverse Willard hypothesis no Hamilton
so what am I talking about
um
Hamilton's hypothesis anyway never mind
all that I was there focused on lizards
one day uh I
um so Bob has a house on the hill and I
came he was getting ready I think to go
out he was going out to a dance and he
was getting dressed and I came by and he
was uh he's like hey Brett
check this out and it's a blue animal on
his
mirror
sideways to the Mirror signaling and
looking at its own reflection and
um the interpretation that we both came
to I actually went to grab it to see if
I could assess anything about it he's
like no don't do that you're doing
animal behavior here man right don't
touch the lizard don't touch the lizard
and so anyway the interpretation was
that the animal was signaling to a rival
in its own mind that was
perfectly matched there was no way that
either individual was going to to back
down on the basis that it had been uh
outflanked and that it just remained
there as I recall it remained for some
days uh perched there ready to defeat
tires although now that you mentioned
I'm feeling a little tired
um so anyway yeah that was that
very cool
uh okay we're gonna stop soon here
um
how much Chesterton have you read
a bit a bit in uh in writing
the book uh but not uh he's he's a good
writer in addition to having just a
wealth of ideas
um but not as much as I might have liked
to but man it's the stack of things I'd
like to read big so
yeah the answer is a little for me but
not much
uh can you acknowledge that
environmentalism is a factless fanatical
religion yet
I know no
um but what you mean by environmentally
yeah environmentalism is capitalized so
you know maybe that's like big ass
science right so you know just like as I
said in the in the main part of the
podcast you know we've been I've been
talking to people who actually care
about sustainability actually care about
conservation
as contrasted with people who put that
in their bios and and make careers out
of it but don't actually know what
they're doing or or care anything about
it so a lot of what passes for
environmentalism is garbage of course of
course and for many people
um because it's fashionable uh it is it
is a primary flag that they that they
wave even if they don't really have any
idea what they're doing so you know
that's that's true
um but the idea that the environment
ought to be one of our primary concerns
we have one planet and we are
cutting down forests putting roads in
places that have never had roads before
which gives access to Interiors of
habitat that have never had access
before for not just humans but the
pathogens we bring organisms that use
the roads that aren't humans we've got
you know glyphosate and other
agrochemicals everywhere we've got you
know a giant plastic Geyer in the middle
of Pacific and you know we can go on and
on and on and on and we didn't even have
to ever mention climate right
um so that's the conflation that most
people will make is environmentalism
equals uh uh the only thing that we must
do is focus on anthrogenic climate
change
that's not the same thing
so I would argue that actually
sustainability has to be our I can't say
it has to be our top priority but over
the long term that has to be true
because everything else is subordinate
to it right our ability to live well on
the earth our ability to generate wealth
our ability to persist our ability to
protect ourselves all of these things
are dependent on us not degrading the
planet over time which we are doing
extremely rapidly and if you are
expert enough to look at a habitat over
time and to understand how it's changing
the rate at which we are degrading the
place is extremely rapid and very
alarming so anyway sustainability almost
inherently
would be the top concern for any wise
population
for some populations in some ways of
making a living in the world
uh it may be a non-issue because they're
self-regulating but for any
technological culture it should be
um the top thing which doesn't mean the
other stuff isn't important it's just
it's the one that you know you can go
through 40 Years of tyranny but if you
destroy
that would on which we depend it much of
it cannot be resurrected so I think
that's a a misapprehension that people
have
yeah
okay uh quickly two two last questions
um
is the Waf the final boss or are they
just a front for a greater dysfunction
yeah they it's hard to say I I don't I
don't think they are
the boss I think they are a symptom of
whatever
boss function is
um they do seem awfully cartoonish and
it's hard to imagine
yeah running the show yeah it does it
seems to
yeah too cartoonish as you say yeah
what do you think of clean that is to
say lab-grown meat
terrible yeah I think it's a terrible
idea you're going to be disgusting and
it is going to be
um bad for your health yeah it's
virtually guaranteed if I was in a
position
where I had to get my protein from
lab-grown meat like
Lab Ground cow or pork versus insects I
would go with insects for sure yeah yeah
100 cricket stick isn't bad you know and
I
we've both I've I've had insects a
couple times in the tropics you know
street food and I haven't liked it
they're not good I you know I don't have
any of the cultural expectations that I
will like it and it seems grotesque in
all of this but it's they're real
animals
that provide you know that lived some
real life and now you can convert that
into energy as opposed to
um whatever the hell is going on with
the lab ground meat yeah I just don't
see how it could possibly not be a
a health problem yeah I also find it
unlikely that it is going to have
proper consistency to be pleasant and so
my fear is that they will go full Burger
King on it and they will basically treat
the production
of the proteins separate from the issue
of texture and taste and they will make
sense they're going to add flavor at it
later flavor added to taste flavor color
pasture are going to be dealt with in
post-production and
it's gonna be nasty and
I don't need that stuff you go ahead I'm
just not gonna eat with you
yeah I mean they also the baked beets
the veggie based meats are predictably I
mean it doesn't even they they I
wouldn't even predict to be terrible for
your health because
it seems like oh you're just making it
out of vegetables or whatever so it's
not as good as meat but like it's still
good they're awful they're now the
fillers and the gums and the things that
are sticking them together well on the
seed oil just everything about them are
really truly awful for you and so you
sort of it's the same people just being
like here's our next best thing well
your first thing was worse than not
eating most of the time
try again yeah totally
all right guys uh it's been it's been
long it's been weird here we are that's
February for you oh
um
not usually
we're only four days in yes we're
seventh the way through it wow I know
yeah yeah okay
um
we will be back next week not with a q a
we won't be doing a q a next week
um but we will be back uh with our main
episode next week
and
yeah until we see you next time be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside hang in there March is
coming
[Music]